commencer notre
commission de ce matin
et notre réunion aujourd'hui porte sur
un sujet que nous avons malheureusement
trop peu l'occasion d'aborder celui de
la Francophonie sujet qui je sais vous
tient à cœur aux uns et aux autres il
m'a semblé en effet important que nous
puissions nous en saisir de nouveau
alors que la Cité internationale de la
France de la langue française de
Villers-Cotterêts devrait être devait
être inauguré le 25 juin prochain
échéance qui a finalement été reporté à
la fin de l'été cette actualité certes
retardée
tombe néanmoins un point puisque
après un nommé puisque le groupe
d'études francophonie rattaché à notre
commission vient d'être constitué sous
la nouvelle présidence de Yann
chanterrel dont je salue le volontarisme
et l'ambition sur son programme de
travail tel qu'il l'a présenté au groupe
d'études il y a quelques jours afin de
nous éclairer sur les grands enjeux et
des filles qui se posent à la
Francophonie nous avons l'honneur et le
plaisir d'accueillir Jacques Toubon en
tant qu' ancien ministre de la culture
et de la Francophonie et et je crois
votre voisin qui me l'a glissé à
l'oreille il y a quelques minutes en
toute modestie je ne le savais pas que
vous avez été le seul ministre à la fois
de la culture et de la Francophonie
ceux qui ont dit beaucoup est une
compétence et un service du Quai d'Orsay
qui
depuis que
les années 70 à très jalousement pris
soin de ne jamais
confier le soin de cette affaire à ceux
qui
je le dis très franchement sur le fond
sont beaucoup plus compétents parce
qu'ils sont pas diplomates c'est-à-dire
les spécialistes de la culture et de la
langue j'ai réussi moi en arrivant en
a obtenu du Premier ministre de l'époque
Édouard Balladur
que le service de la Francophonie soit
rattaché non pas
hiérarchiquement mais pour usage
au ministère de la Culture
c'est fait le ministère s'est appelé
culturel francophonie et pendant deux
ans j'ai en fait dirigé le service de la
Francophonie et mener à ce nombre
d'action grâce à ce service et dès que
en 1995 après ils Chirac Alain Juppé et
devenu premier ministre j'ai moi-même
changé de poste au gouvernement
le Quai d'Orsay a repris ses compétences
et son organisation et nous n'avons plus
jamais entendu parler de la Francophonie
autrement que comme un service de notre
diplomatie et je c'est une vous avez
bien fait de mettre ça parce que c'est
très très caractéristique de ce que
il y a encore beaucoup de choses que
nous n'avons pas compris dans ce domaine
pardon
si vous êtes là aussi ce matin c'est
bien sûr parce que vous êtes l'auteur de
la loi fondatrice du 4 août
1994 dont nous fêterons l'année
prochaine le 30e anniversaire la loi qui
porte votre nom et puis bien entendu pas
de cinétique délégué général à la langue
française et aux langues de France que
nous avons déjà reçu au sein de notre
commission et qui vient de remettre au
Parlement son rapport sur la langue
française plusieurs aspects me
paraissent devoir être approfondie avec
vous ce matin d'abord le contexte
socio-économique technologique culturel
et géopolitique dans lequel nous sommes
et qui influent inévitablement sur la
francophonie et ses contours je pense
par exemple à l'échéance des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 qui
constitue à la fois une chance pour la
promotion de notre langue et un risque
compte tenu de la prédominance de
l'anglais dans ce genre de manifestation
internationales ensuite les qui vient de
l'État dont l'état dispose ou devrait
disposer pour assurer sa mission de
garant de la langue française quel rôle
devra jouer la future cité
internationale de la langue française
qui avant même son inauguration et déjà
un peu décrié l'arsenal législative que
constitue la loi tout bon doit-il être
actualisé pour tenir compte des
évolutions notamment technologiques en
particulier des sortes du numérique et
sociétales à l'oeuvre depuis son
adoption l'enseignement du français en
France et à l'international mérite-t-il
d'être repensé mieux doté face à la
concurrence de l'anglais mais aussi
d'autres longues d'autres langues pardon
et on peut penser au mandarin par
exemple cette liste de questions n'est
pas exhaustive et je suis sûr que mes
collègues ne monteront pas de vous
interroger et d'aborder d'autres sujets
qui traitent de la Francophonie
mais sans plus tarder je vais vous
laisser la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes et
puis ensuite après bien sûr nous
fonctionnerons sous forme de
questions-réponses monsieur ministre
monsieur le Président d'abord je vous
remercie de m'avoir convié ensuite je
remercie la commission des affaires
culturelles du Sénat
d'être depuis très longtemps je dirais
depuis toujours
probablement l'une des institutions et
en tout cas
parmi les politiques les plus attentifs
à
cette question de la langue française et
quelquefois même seule lorsque le sujet
est abandonné par tout le monde donc je
pense que cette
très opportun que à un an maintenant de
cette tombe d'événements
nous entretenions de cette affaire je ne
je ne ferai naturellement aucune
révélation particulière je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui chacun le sait de
compétences ou de ou de position
particulière mais je crois pouvoir
apporter un certain nombre de choses
alors d'abord je crois qu'il y a
cette à la fin de cette au milieu de
cette année 2023 les choses se
présentent sous deux aspects le premier
je pense que vous l'avez souligné de
Président c'est les événements qui vont
de toute façon nous obliger à
bouger ou apprendre position et on en a
moi il y en a au moins 4 il y a le 30e
anniversaire de la loi il y a les Jeux
Olympiques et je rappelle je l'ai déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises que le français
est à égal de l'anglais la langue
olympique et que la première chose à
faire pour l'année prochaine je
olympique de Paris c'est de faire en
sorte que le français soit utilisé comme
l'anglais dans toute la communication
des Jeux Olympiques a égalité et le
Parlement a sur ce point un rôle
essentiel et j'ai même je crois dit un
certain nombre d'entre vous ou je ne
sais dans résistance il faut que
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ensemble adopte une résolution demandant
au gouvernement de faire respecter ces
dispositions de la Charte olympique qui
date de 1920 et pas de la loi tout bon
droit troisièmement nous aurons un
sommet de la Francophonie
et enfin nous n'oublions pas nous aurons
à la fin d'année 2023 la Coupe du monde
de rugby or c'est un événement
extrêmement populaire c'est un sport qui
est marqué par une utilisation intensive
de l'anglais et les rugbyman se font
même une sorte de snobisme de parler
anglais plutôt que que le français du
Sud-Ouest mais mais mais mais
je pense que il faut utiliser aussi
cette événement donc nous avons là des
circonstances dans lesquelles il faut
non seulement que nous défendions la
position du français et je l'ai dit de
manière très précise sur les Jeux
olympiques mais la diversité des langues
qui seront
utilisés et je crois que il y a là
quelque chose
nous devons être les promoteurs de ce
que ces grands événements qui
rassemblent tous les peuples permettent
à tous les peuples de s'exprimer dans
leur propre laurier nous devons donc
mener une politique une action une
communication qui ne soit pas seulement
au profit de notre propre langue
français mais de la diversité des des
langues et bien entendu on aura le temps
d'en parler
l'émergence et la la les migration de
Villers-Cotterêts va participer de tous
ces événements donc nous avons 23 24 une
séquence extrêmement importante le la
deuxième et et je pense que le Sénat
doit prendre avec l'Assemblée nationale
de fortes positions dans ce domaine nous
avons nous avons
le deuxième sujet qui est naturellement
la loi pas parce que c'est le 30e
anniversaire mais parce que il convient
de se poser la question
à cette occasion autrement de savoir si
il faut d'une manière ou d'une autre la
faire avancer je veux pas être long dans
cette introduction je crois qu'il y a
quatre points qui méritent d'évidence
d'être regardés et d'être regardé en
particulier par les spécialistes et les
juristes du Parlement et notamment du
Sénat le premier point c'est
les sanctions actuelles
sont-elles suffisantes ou suffisamment
appliquées alors la réponse est non mais
en même temps l'ancien garde des sceaux
que je suis aussi répond mais les
magistrats font ce qu'ils veulent et et
et je pense que c'est un principe au
moins aussi important que celui de
défendre la langue française c'est à
dire la séparation des pouvoirs
l'indépendance de la justice et notre
système d'état de droite bon donc
afficher dans la loi une très forte
augmentation des sanctions est-ce que ça
aboutirait à mieux les appliquer je
ne sais pas mais mais en tout cas le
Parlement peut prendre l'initiative
là-dessus
deuxièmement nous avons été victime
je dis victime parce que je pense que ça
a été un grand dommage
en 94
lorsque le Conseil constitutionnel a
examiné la loi que je j'avais fait voter
au Parlement à la demande du groupe
socialiste de l'époque qui avait envoyé
la loi au Conseil constitutionnel pour
atteindre à la liberté d'expression
le conseil nous a donc fait sauter en
gros je résume l'article 2 c'est-à-dire
l'application de la loi aux
communications privées
probablement il est impossible de
surmonter cette jurisprudence
constitutionnelle évidemment mais je
pense que il y aurait peut-être la
possibilité de rechercher le moyen de
mettre en oeuvre ou des éléments de la
loi dans la communication privée
troisièmement troisièmement il y a les
questions alors qui ne sont pas
proprement parler dans la loi mais qui
sont extrêmement importantes c'est le
contenu de la langue donc tout le
travail absolument formidable sur la
terminologie
j'ai ici ce dernier petit
document qui a été publié par la
Commission d'environnement dans le
langue française et qui est
50 termes qui ont été
inventés entre 72 et 2002 on a là un
travail formidable l'écocide le le
crédit bail et la bientraitance animale
et tout ça voilà ça c'est du français et
et c'est tous les jours tous les jours
c'est pas pour les académiciens c'est
vraiment et et la dernière remarque que
que
je veux faire elle est évidente elle est
énorme mais
quelle solution
c'est il faut adapter la loi à l'air du
numérique et du numérique des
algorithmes et maintenant désormais de
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle va nous
faire du français va nous faire du
nouveau français celui de l'intelligence
artificielle va nous faire du
globish va voilà et je pense que
il est très important que notamment dans
les textes qui je le sais au Parlement
seront consacrés à l'économie numérique
au numérique le souci de la langue
apparaissent mais aussi si vous vous
attaquez à une amélioration de la loi du
4 août 94 ne pas oublier que le chapitre
numérique est aujourd'hui absolument
indispensable voilà c'est ce que ce que
je je voulais dire vraiment ces quelques
minutes d'introduction et
je suis simplement
extrêmement
heureux de pouvoir parler avec vous de
cela en terminant en disant simplement
que
la dimension du problème
est
aujourd'hui
évidente et je crois qu'il faut toujours
le répéter nous sommes la 4e ou la 5e
langue parlée dans le monde mais
il y a un grand nombre de pays qui sont
marqués par l'usage du du français et je
pense que ce n'est pas seulement un
phénomène post-colonial
bien au-delà
et je crois que
c'est une action ça s'appelle la
francophonie mais c'est bien au-delà je
crois qu'il faut que nous soyons
soucieux de tenir notre rang partout où
il y a des hommes et des femmes qui
pensent que s'exprimer en français c'est
mieux ou en tout cas c'est aussi bien
que dans d'autres langues qu'on leur
propose et notamment
la langue des publicités merci
merci Monsieur de cinétique
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
grand honneur pour moi de parler après
monsieur le ministre Jacques Toubon à
qui l'on doit tout en ce qui concerne
comme vous le savez le cadre légal et la
possibilité aujourd'hui qu'on nous
concitoyens à pouvoir s'exprimer et
accéder à des informations en français
c'est donc pour moi un grand joie et un
grand honneur que d'être que d'être à
vos côtés chez Jacques Toubon merci de
votre invitation monsieur le Président
alors je vais pas faire un long exposé
parce que je pense que en effet l'objet
de cette rencontre s'est engager un
dialogue avec avec la représentation
nationale avec vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous rappelez
quand même que l'État est engagé pour
mettre en place une politique publique
en matière linguistique à travers
l'action de la Délégation générale à la
langue française et langue de France
dont la mission c'était précisément
d'animer la politique publique en
matière linguistique du gouvernement et
cette délégation contribue pleinement
et à ce titre au projet formidable
projet présidentiel de la Cité
internationale de la langue française à
Villers-Cotterêts qui a pu être décrié
mais qui a pu être aussi et je préfère
permettez-moi monsieur le Président de
voir le verre aux trois quarts plein
plutôt qu'au par vide qui a pu être
aussi vivement encouragé car ce projet
de la Cité internationale de la langue
française est appelé à illustrer les
réalités de notre de notre politique
publique en matière linguistique
rappelez aussi très très brièvement que
la délégation générale la langue
française est une administration de
mission classée auprès de la ministre
Riva Abdul Malak qui vaille à l'emploi
du français donc de la République
article 2 de notre Constitution l'emploi
du français en France et qui contribue
monsieur le ministre Jacques Toubon l'a
rappelé à l'enrichissement de notre
langue à travers un remarquable travail
de terminologie dont vous avez quelques
exemples
à travers les brochures qui vous ont été
distribués ce matin
notre mission est aussi d'assurer la
promotion des langues de France on
entend par l'angle de France langue
régionale et langue non territoriale qui
font partie du patrimoine de notre pays
selon l'article 75-1 de la Constitution
et nous contribuons également avec
l'ensemble des services du ministère de
la Culture à la diffusion de notre
langue et de la Francophonie dans le
monde
je trouve très intéressant le choix de
cette thématique autour de la
Francophonie et en nous ayant invité
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
Délégation générale à la langue
française de langue de France pour
parler d'abord de l'objet de la langue
car c'est c'est bien la langue qui fait
la francophonie et s'il n'y a pas de
politique
concertés avec les autres ministères au
plan gouvernemental au premier rang
desquels le ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale il ne peut pas y
avoir d'espace francophone il ne peut
pas y avoir de dialogue francophone il
ne peut en effet y avoir de politique
linguistique ne soient globale croisant
les approches nationales et
internationales sans prendre en compte
pleinement ses réalités
alors vous avez souhaité nous interroger
sur sur un certain nombre de sujets le
calendrier des grands événements
naturellement les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui se tiendront en France
en
2024 mais aussi le ministre Jacques
Toubon l'a rappelé la Coupe du monde de
rugby
en fonction d'un contexte je cite
socio-économique technologiques culturel
et géopolitique sur la francophonie et
ses contours
je rajouterais donc un autre point à
notre réflexion ce matin qui est celui
déjà esquissé par Jacques Toubon de
l'intelligence artificielle du grand
défi de l'innovation qui pose la
question de l'avenir de notre langue
d'ailleurs de l'avenir du pluriel cuisse
de l'ensemble des langues comment la
France comment l'Europe comment les
espaces francophones vont réagir par
rapport à ce défi de l'intelligence
artificielle alors très concrètement
pour pour répondre déjà à la première
question
posée sur les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques nous avons mis en place
avec avec nos collègues du ministère des
Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques le 22 novembre dernier un
groupe de travail interministériel et un
institutionnel intitulé le français
langue du sport et de l'olympisme en
France et dans le monde ce groupe de
travail associe des représentants du
ministère culture du ministère des
sports du ministère de l'Europe des
Affaires étrangères de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse de la
délégation interministériale des Jeux
Olympiques et par olympiques du Kojo des
associations représentant les
collectivités et les réseaux
territoriaux de l'ensemble des
fédérations sportives 4 thématiques ont
été retenues pour déboucher d'ici la fin
de l'année sur des livrables et des
recommandations car il s'agit d'agir
être vigilant c'est certain pour que le
français soit au même titre que
l'anglais la langue de ce grand
rendez-vous mais pour être plus concret
encore quatre thématiques vont être
explorées à travers des recommandations
qui sont proposées par ces groupes de
travail et c'est ces titres les titres
de ces de ces thématiques sont
évocateurs entreprises du sport et
francophonie ressources pédagogiques et
éducatives au service des francophones
le le Lexico sport
vous allez parlez-vous surf parlez-vous
break tous ces termes qui ont été mis en
place par la commission d'enrichissement
à langue française pour pour exprimer en
français les réalités les plus
contemporaines des disciplines sportives
et notamment des disciplines du sport
urbain
sont également sont également prises en
compte et nous allons lancer des
applications
numériques des sites internet afin que
ces vocabulaire soit accessible et
empruntés par le plus grand nombre et
enfin un quatrième sujet qui concerne la
mobilisation des collectivités
territoriales pour valoriser la langue
française dans le cadre des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques évidemment
cette action n'est pas à un seul coup il
s'inscrit dans le plan héritage dans les
grands rendez-vous sportifs qui vont qui
vont être mises en œuvre en France et
également ils sont appelés à ces elles
sont appelées ces actions à devenir
pérenne pour pouvoir
diffuser
lors des prochains rendez-vous des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques je pense
notamment à rendez-vous au rendez-vous
de Los Angeles
deuxième sujet deuxième grand défi
qui qui nous mobilise pleinement le
ministre l'a rappelé c'est le défi de
l'intelligence artificielle alors que
aujourd'hui les technologies de la
langue les interfaces hommes machines de
l'intelligence artificielle prenne une
place de plus en plus importante dans
notre société une part croissante des
contenus que nous lisons et entendons
son produit par des machines et d'autant
plus avec la banalisation de ce que nous
appelons les les agents conversationnels
comme Tchad jipiti dont les cas d'usage
sont sans limites et pour certains
fortement médiatisés et problématiques
alors
j'ai cette réflexion avec vous que je
suis heureux de pouvoir engager
réfléchissons à l'avenir et la forme des
langues qui se joue pour l'essentiel
aujourd'hui à travers cette technologie
c'est pour cette raison que le ministère
de la Culture en lien très étroit avec
le ministère de l'Économie le
secrétariat d'État transition numérique
en appui aussi le coordinateur national
l'intelligence artificielle
projette de de réaliser un centre de
référence détectologie de la langue
intitulée linguya qui est dédié à ce
secteur au secteur du traitement
automatique des langues pour mieux
accompagner le monde académique et
industriel français et en particulier
les prêts de 200 jeunes pousses qui
représentent un savoir-faire
d'excellence en France et que nous à
tout prix accompagné
ce centre dont l'amorçage est prévu sur
des crédits France 2030 pourrait être
mise en lien avec le projet de la Cité
internationale de la langue française à
Villers-Cotterêts en 2025 mais si vous
me permettez il faut aller aller plus
vite plus haut plus loin
si tu es sportulus Altus pour parler
latin le marché des technologies vous le
savez est estimé en 2022 à 341 milliards
de dollars et promis à une croissance
annuelle de 27 points 6% d'ici 2030
selon une étude récente de market reser
futur de septembre 2022 et ces chiffres
précèdent l'arrivée de Tchad jibity donc
ils sont très largement sous-estimés
les acteurs majeurs aujourd'hui ont le
sait sont américains comment allons-nous
réagir nous ne pouvons réagir évidemment
de façon concrète et et
crédible qu'avec la pluie de l'ensemble
des pays membres de l'Union européenne
c'est pour cette raison que elle la
demande de Bruxelles nous étudions la
faisabilité la possibilité de la
création d'un consortium industriel
dédié aux technologies de la langue un
consortium industriel européen qui qui
permettra ainsi de développer des outils
souverains et compétitifs prenez en
prenant en compte les les
spécificités linguistiques de chaque
pays et naturellement les conciliants
avec nos enjeux de faible consommation
énergétique car la France notre pays
possède des atouts
extraordinaires pour se positionner
comme chef de fil européen des
infrastructures comme le
supercalculateur Jean Zay la formation
des parmi les meilleurs mathématiciens
au monde on ne compte plus le nombre de
médailles field des institutions de
recherche pertinentes et dynamiques qui
font de notre pays
un cadre idéal pour l'intelligence
artificielle européenne
et puis nous avons un autre sujet que je
me permets d'esquisser
qui concerne davantage la diffusion de
nos de nos savoirs de nos contenus en
langue française a commencé par des
contenus scientifiques
sur les objets du numérique a commencé
par Internet et à cet effet d'où nous
allons réaliser une mission sur la
découvrabilité des contenus
scientifiques en français une mission
qui sera inscrite dans la prochaine
rencontre alternée des deux premiers
ministres françaises et québécois
d'ici la fin de l'année cette mission
devra elle aussi déboucher sur des
recommandations très concrètes pour
permettre que notre langue soit encore
une langue de diffusion une langue
d'influence et lui assurer ainsi à
travers l'ensemble des objets connectés
numériques une une pérennité crédible
alors le projet de Villers-Cotterêts
vous m'avez interrogé monsieur le
Président sur sur cette formidable
opportunité parce que moi je considère
que c'est une formidable opportunité
pour incarner cette politique de la
langue ce projet de Villers-Cotterêts
c'est d'abord et le président lorsqu'il
était président du Centre des monuments
nationaux Philippe Belaval l'avait
maintes fois rappelé auprès de vous un
projet de restauration du patrimoine car
le château de Villers-Cotterêts c'était
l'un des plus grands scandales du
patrimoine en France grâce à l'action
décisive de l'État nous avons pu relever
l'ensemble des bâtiments et quand je dis
nous c'est évidemment au Centre des
monuments nationaux qu'il en revient le
mérite et afin d'y installer selon les
voeux du Président de la République
qu'il avait qu'il avait qu'il avait
indiqué lors de son discours dont vous
avez tous souvenir sous la Coupole de
l'Institut de France en mars 2018
ce discours intitulé un nouvel ambition
pour la langue française est le plus
rilinguisme d'y installer donc au sein
de cette cité la cité de ce château
pardon François 1er oblige ordonnance de
Villers-Cotterêts ou de 1539 oblige la
Cité internationale de la langue
française et
c'est une c'est une opportunité réelle
qui qui permettra me semble-t-il d'aller
dans quatre directions suivantes nos
objectifs de politique linguistiques
première direction direction prenant
pleinement en compte les réalités du
territoire langue française langue de
cohésion on est sur un territoire à
Villers-Cotterêts vous le savez qui est
marqué par un taux d'illettrisme
important près du double de la moyenne
nationale on y a 13 %
de ce qui est quand même un taux
particulièrement préoccupant un
département sud de l'Aisne qui est
également marquée par par le chômage
un sentiment de
un sentiment dans le fond de
de délégation
qui qui est persistant au sein de la
population
donc il s'agit de degrés en mettant en
place des actions concrètes et cela a
déjà été entrepris depuis 2 ans pour
permettre à aux habitants de ce
territoire une meilleure appropriation
de ce projet en leur donnant la
possibilité
de mieux maîtriser la langue française
Dieu il adhéré également leur donner des
outils à travers des programmes des
appels à projets qui sont qui sont
proposés spécifiquement des festivals
autour de la langue française bref il
s'agira de doter Villers-Cotterêts d'un
équipement linguistique de la même façon
que un établissement culturel est doté
d'un équipement culturel
deuxième objectif deuxième enjeu
linguistique pour Villers-Cotterêts
c'est j'ai dit langue langue française
langue de cohésion deuxième enjeu pour
moi c'est langue française langue de
création et d'attractivité
des résidences une programmation
culturelle
des chercheurs des créateurs qui ont
pour matériaux de travail premier la
langue française et la francophonie
seront ainsi invités dans le cadre de
cette cité pour y produire des des
travaux et
les et les valoriser troisième c'est
aussi un enjeu naturellement très
important pour l'attractivité au plan
international vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que l'Organisation internationale
de la Francophonie avec sa secrétaire
général louise Mushikiwabo a déjà signé
des accords de partenariat avec avec le
Centre des monuments nationaux de
nombreux de nombreux échanges ont déjà
lieu avec un grand nombre de partenaires
francophones
le Québec et le Canada naturellement
en première ligne
donc il y a tout un travail
d'attractivité et de et de rayonnement
international le troisième grand enjeu
de politique linguistique dit langue
française langue de cohésion langue
française langue de création
d'attractivité et de diffusion langue
française
langue d'innovation et là on revient à
ce sujet qui nous mobilise qui doit nous
mobiliser y compris autant au plan
interministériel du grand défi à relever
posé par l'intelligence artificielle et
le traitement automatique des langues
le choix de Villers-Cotterêts pour moi
c'est un choix très très symbolique
aussi car outre le fait que
c'est dans cet endroit que fut signé
l'ordonnance de la de qui fit de la
langue française la langue du droit on
l'a dit c'est un endroit c'est un
territoire qui est marqué par par un par
des nombreuses difficultés
socioculturelles socio-économiques et
c'est aussi un grand défi à relever car
dans le fond
du point de vue inédit
c'est la première fois qu'on réalise une
cité des dialogues françaises alors il
peut y avoir
il y avoir comme pour tout enfantement
quelques difficultés quelques
hésitations mais l'ambition elle est
elle est réelle elle est forte les
moyens ont été ont été engagés aussi
d'importants moyens humains d'apporter
au moyen financiers pour réussir cette
entreprise et je trouve que c'est une
aventure passionnante qui sera proposée
à travers la réalisation de cette de
cette cité
c'est une aventure qui d'ailleurs qui
aura pu influencer aussi un certain
nombre d'autres d'autres initiatives
prises par la suite par d'autres pays
d'Europe tiens c'est intéressant on se
rend compte que le plurilinguisme c'est
un sujet qui concerne pas que la France
je pense à l'Espagne ou en ce moment
même un centre dédié à la lent aux
langues espagnoles est en train d'être
réalisé dans la vallée de la Ria avec un
important investissement de la part de
l'État je pense à des initiatives qui
sont prises également en Italie pour
faire un centre de la langue italienne
non loin de Florence les Allemands sont
très attentifs donc on voit aussi qu'à
travers cette initiative de la Cité
internationale de la langue française la
France joue un rôle de moteur de
dynamique pour engager et faire prendre
conscience à nos partenaires les plus
proches des pays de l'Union européenne
de la nécessité de l'urgence d'une
politique linguistique le ministre
Jacques Toubon a évoqué l'importance du
cadre légal je ne vais pas revenir sur
sur son
sa nécessité absolue aujourd'hui
quelques chiffres quand même
selon un selon un récent sont une raison
enquête pardon que nous avions commandé
que nous avions commandé au CREDOC
l'importance de ce cadre légal il est
bien il est bien pris en compte par nos
concitoyens plus de deux tiers des
Français sont attachés à la loi tout bon
l'important aussi de la politique de la
langue plus de la moitié des Français
interrogés se voient gêner agacé
d'une certaine façon discriminer
lorsqu'on s'adresse
à eux dans une autre langue que la
langue commune la langue française car
il en va de
cette importance de cohésion de ce
sentiment d'appartenance et le cadre
légal il contribue grandement alors bien
sûr voyons voyons si vous le voulez bien
le vert le vert le vert plutôt vide
le verre plein
il est il est là devant nous avec
avec les réussites du cadre légal
l'obligation de traduire
tous les produits de consommation dans
les notices des produits de consommation
en français
des questions qui garantissent également
la sécurité de nos concitoyens la santé
de nos concitoyens donc
on voit que que ce cadre légal a
beaucoup apporté maintenant si l'on
constate des manquements au cadre légal
ils sont d'autant plus flagrants que
peut-être ils sont qui sont voyants
l'affichage publicitaire
le numérique qui n'était pas pris en
compte
en 1994 car en effet comme vous le savez
la publicité
peut-être faite en d'autres langues en
français sur les supports numériques
des ambiguïtés aussi rédactionnelles je
change notamment à l'article 14 consacré
aux marques employés par les personnes
publiques
quelques points donc de ce cadre légal
qui peuvent marquer une certaine érosion
quant à son efficacité
mais ces difficultés d'application
n'empêche pas la Délégation Générale
langue française et aux langues de
France d'agir en faveur du cadre légal
nous sommes pleinement engagés dans un
effort d'information de sensibilisation
au respect des principes de la loi tout
bon qui vise à responsabiliser les
acteurs concernés au premier chef les
organismes publics nous avons engagé un
dialogue très étroit avec également un
certain nombre d'instance de régulation
je songe à notre ami recolivier Mestre
président de LARCOM à Monsieur Daubert
qui est le président de la RPP et la
journée du 21 mars à laquelle vous aviez
participé monsieur le ministre et qui
avait été tout ouverte d'ailleurs par
Jean-Marc Sauvé président vice-président
honoraires du Conseil d'État rassemblant
plus de 450 participants à l'Institut de
France pour diffuser et promouvoir ce
rapport au Parlement de la langue
française montre à quel point la société
civile est engagée pour que vivent ce
cadre légal
il y a des champs prioritaires
d'intervention la présence du français
dans notre société par grand secteur des
sciences des recherches l'enseignement
supérieur la décourabilité des contenus
en ligne le sport et l'olympisme etc et
l'emploi du français dans le secteur
public les administrations les
institutions les grandes entreprises et
les collectivités
nous avons d'ores et déjà renforcé notre
action au plan terminal j'ai fini avec
la mise en place de lettres de mission
auprès du réseau des hauts
fonctionnaires à la langue française qui
ne sont plus seulement chargés de
l'enrichissement de la langue à travers
leur participation aux travaux du
dispositif d'engissement mais également
qu'ils doivent être chargés de la veille
pour que le cadre légal soit respecté au
sein de leur ministère et des services
publics et puis nous avons vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président publié ce
nouveau rapport au Parlement sur les
politiques en faveur du français et du
pluriel anguisme qui vise avec une
éditorialisation très claire à informer
le mieux possible la représentation
nationale à travers des chiffres clés
qui sont donnés et qui seront actualisés
chaque année mais également plus
généralement les élus et les décideurs
pour leur faire passer ce message
essentiel que la langue française c'est
un objet politique je vous remercie
alors vous êtes plusieurs à vouloir
intervenir je vais prendre toutes vos
questions en commençant bien entendu par
Yann chanterelle qui est le président du
groupe d'études sur la francophonie
comme je le rappelais tout à l'heure
très bien merci monsieur le Président
pour pour cette audition merci à vous en
tout cas pour ces très large c'est très
riche je voulais justement saluer le
travail qui est effectué par la
Délégation Générale qui fait vraiment un
très beau travail de valorisation et
défense de notre langue
alors effectivement on a relancé sous la
gouverne entre entre guillemets de notre
président de commission ce groupe
d'études sur la francophonie et on a
identifié donc un gros comme vous avez
pu l'exposer dans dans votre propos il y
a beaucoup de champs et ce qui est assez
frappant aussi qui nous paraît c'est
important et c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais bien avoir le retour de
l'ancien ministre de la Francophonie
également là-dessus c'est vous avez
vous-même dit dans votre votre propos
qui avait une obligation sur toutes les
politiques qui sont liées à la
Francophonie de concertation ça ne doit
pas être limité qu'un seul ministère
d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup plus vaste
parce que c'est un brique beaucoup de
choses et ce qu'on peut constater
justement c'est peut-être je dirais un
manque de véritables stratégie de vision
politique par rapport à cet espace
francophone permettant de de réellement
mieux exploiter cet espace que
représente la francophonie mieux
exploitée en termes économique en termes
d'échange culturel universitaires à
travers sa richesse
parce que effectivement quand on regarde
les données les évaluations
on évalue à peu près il y a eu beaucoup
de rapports sur ce sujet à peu près à
700 millions de francophones en 2050 700
millions de francophones donc 85% de ces
francophones sont vont être en Afrique
donc ça c'est une donnée quand même
essentielle à avoir en tête une
population en plus en Afrique qui est
très jeune et qui va beaucoup qui
s'informent beaucoup qui est très
présente également sur sur les réseaux
sociaux ou peu peuvent être diffusés des
messages qui ne sont pas toujours des
messages très favorables à la France qui
plus est donc il faut
permettre de créer finalement ce qu'on
appellerait un sentiment d'appartenance
à cet espace plus vaste que nous simples
pays à travers la langue justement au
sein d'un espace francophone d'ailleurs
toutes nos politiques
culturelles le rayonnement sont on a un
réseau très dense on a des
établissements français partout dans le
monde également qui d'ailleurs dans les
établissements français la majorité les
deux tiers ne sont pas des Français ce
sont des résidents locaux qui passent
par nos établissements il y a également
des instituts français les Alliances
françaises qui permettent aussi à
beaucoup de personnes d'apprendre
d'apprendre le français on fait
d'ailleurs la promotion des études
supérieures en France à travers Campus
France sauf qu'il y a un gros problème
le gros problème c'est qu'on a une
politique de visa qui va à
contre-courant de toutes ces de tous ces
investissements et cette politique c'est
quasiment une politique schizophrénique
c'est-à-dire que on investit massivement
on forme des gens et au moment où
éventuellement ils veulent poursuivre
leurs études supérieur en France on dit
non c'est pas pour vous vous imaginez
l'humiliation que subissent ces gens-là
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ce tourne vers
d'autres pays ils vont au Royaume-Uni
ils vont au Canada que les accueils
abra ouvert disons en plus vous avez été
formé par des établissements français
pour nous c'est super on vous accueille
avec plaisir et en plus ils ont besoin
de main d'oeuvre importante et pour une
raison simple les visas sont désormais
entre les mains du ministère de
l'intérieur ça n'a pas été le cas
auparavant pendant de très nombreuses
années c'est seulement très récemment
c'était une attribution du ministère des
Affaires étrangères parce que il faut
justement quand on a absolument donc
voilà c'est vous et donc
oui oui non non tout à fait et donc il
faut justement si on veut permettre une
vision une politique de développement
dans cet espace parce que c'est un
levier économique 8% de la population
potentielle un rapport de Jacques Attali
là-dessus pour montrer le levier
économique que peut représenter cette
espace francophone il faut permettre
justement d'avoir des politiques
cohérentes en la matière et non pas
contre-productive on le voit notamment
avec la politique des visas au Maroc qui
suscitent des grands hommes mais c'est
pas le seul pays bien il y a beaucoup de
pays je fais beaucoup de déplacements en
tant que parlementaire représentant les
Français établir de France dans l'espace
francophone où je rencontre aussi
beaucoup d'homologues dans ces pays-là
et je peux vous dire que c'est toujours
un crève-cœur de voir ces gens amoureux
de la France et des fois c'est souvent
d'ailleurs des chercheurs et méritent
dans leur pays ce sont des artistes qui
ne peuvent pas pour une simple raison de
d'attribution de visa venir dans le pays
alors que les dernières années il
venaient sans aucun problème et il ne
pose aucun problème donc ça il y a un
vrai il y a une vraie difficulté
là-dessus après il y a un autre point
que vous avez soulevé qui est peut-être
quelque chose qui est un peu minoré en
France c'est le sujet de la
découvrabilité des offres culturelles
francophones sur les plateformes
numériques donc c'est l'invisibilisation
de l'offre culturelle en français sur
les plateformes numériques qui émergent
de manière importante à travers Netflix
notamment mais Disney ou tout un tas de
compagnies américaines qui
malheureusement nous n'avons pas la
maîtrise sur l'algorithme il y a des il
y a des catalogues très importants mais
ce qui compte ça n'est pas d'être
présent dans le catalogue c'est d'être
visible quand on va sur ces plateformes
là il y a par exemple vous avez cité le
Canada le Canada a justement voté
récemment une loi qui s'appelle la loi
C11 qui oblige justement les plateformes
numériques telles que Netflix YouTube ça
va même sur les réseaux sociaux TikTok à
promouvoir le contenu canadien et
également à y contribuer donc ça je
pense que c'est une avenue aussi
importante et intéressante pour nous
pour faire vivre et quand on dit
visibiliser les contenus les contenus en
français ce sont pas que les contenus de
production française ce sont la
diversité des contenus dans la
francophonie au sein de l'espace
francophone il y a des œuvres si on veut
valoriser l'espace francophone c'est
important de valoriser aussi sa
diversité
de contenu au sein de de nos plateformes
donc je voulais savoir si vous aviez
également une réflexion par rapport à
comment permettre justement parce que
les choses la technique va plus vite
finalement que les législateurs on le
voit bien avec justement vous l'avez
évoqué l'intelligence artificielle qui
accélère encore plus les enjeux liés au
numérique donc si vous avez également
des idées des propositions par rapport
qui permettraient d'améliorer et de
permettre de tout en
permettant la production française tout
en permettant aussi sa visibilisation
sur ces plateformes Merci à VOUS Max
Brisson
si tu veux on peut alors pierre
ouzouillas
comme mon intervention sera un peu
décalé
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur le Délégué Général
merci beaucoup pour pour tous vos propos
moi j'aimerais avoir un propos sur la
science et l'usage du français dans la
science nous le savons la langue n'est
pas seulement un vecteur de
communication c'est aussi un mode de
réflexion c'est un mode de pensée et ce
qui fait que les langues ne sont pas
totalement
interchangeables vous l'avez dit très
justement une langue est vivante quand
elle est utilisée dans tous les secteurs
de l'activité humaine et aussi dans le
secteur de la science avec ma collègue
lors d'arkos dans la loi sur la
programmation de la recherche nous avons
fait passer plusieurs dispositifs sur
l'usage du français dont la mise en
oeuvre par les opérateurs de la
recherche et à peu près nul
on nous a on nous a expliqué à plusieurs
reprises et des grands patrons
d'opérateurs de la que la bataille du
français était perdue et qu'il fallait
accepter que les les chercheurs
s'expriment en anglais
la raison je pense que c'est pas celle
de la diffusion parce que même si on
peut être critique par rapport à
l'intelligence artificielle la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
traduire un article en français pour en
comprendre l'essentiel la raison elle
tient elle tient plutôt à la domination
anglo-saxonne sur les vecteurs de la
publication scientifique et ces grandes
revues qui tiennent complètement le
marché de la publication ne souhaite pas
ouvrir leurs colonnes à d'autres langues
que ce qu'on appelle le français et qui
est un affreux globiche comme vous
l'avez dit très justement donc on voit
très bien que pour que la France
redevienne une langue scientifique ce
qu'elle a été pendant longtemps il y a
tout un travail à faire sur de
l'économie de la publication qui réclame
des efforts importants et pour le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche un changement total dans sa
façon d'évaluer les travaux
scientifiques d'évaluer aussi la
production des établissements on avait
essayé nous ici
commission de la culture avec le hcrs et
là on aurait besoin de votre relais pour
pour expliquer que que c'est pas quelque
chose d'accessoire c'est quelque chose
de fondamental pour l'usage du français
merci monsieur le Président Catherine
Morin de saillie
Jacques Toubon et le travail immense et
fondateur qu'il a fait avec cette loi
qui est une référence et peut-être que
on néglige de faire vivre plus souvent
pour promouvoir et défendre notre langue
alors certes le gouvernement a des
projets tels que Villers-Cotterêts mais
moi je m'interroge sur la la cohérence
quand je vois qu'il y a quelques jours
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière le
slogan la promotion de la tract
d'activité de notre économie choisie par
le ministère des Affaires étrangères
vous le savez très bien cher pour le
cinétique parce que vous en étiez plein
il y a deux ans c'est choes France
comme si choisissait la France n'était
pas assez transparent
afficher comme tel bon c'est pas la
première fois qu'il y a de la part du
ministère des Affaires étrangères parce
que c'est de lui que dépensait être
promotion ce genre de
positionnement moi qui m'interroge voilà
moi à l'époque j'avais l'occasion de
m'en ouvrir à Jean-Yves Le Drian mais le
tien n'a pas du tout été corrigé c'est
que vous étiez monté au créneau
de cinétique pour souligner pour
souligner cela alors juste un petit mot
sur la francophonie numérique puisque
c'est un sujet que vous avez développé à
travers la procréation que nous devrions
avoir des nouvelles technologies et de
l'IA je pense que ça passe par
des investissements à réaliser en France
mais surtout en Europe
en faveur de ces nouvelles technologies
on est très en deçà forcément des grands
pays comme les États-Unis et la Chine
mais notre investissement était vraiment
peau de chagrin dernières années dans le
plan d'action 2030 la boussole numérique
vous regarderez bien il y a pas de
dispositif spécifiques prévus et de
plans d'action alors comment ça
s'émouvoir face parlez-moi je parle
anglais parce que c'est l'inflation
américain on voit bien que tout ça
risque aussi de d'aspirer nos propres
entreprises à la fois aux États-Unis
mais aussi chez Yann au Canada où il y a
des investissements très fortement
consentis dans ce domaine là donc moi je
pense la francophonie numérique elle
passe aussi par des investissements
l'appropriation de ces nouvelles
technologies et le développement
d'écosystèmes
spécifiques et je pense qu'il serait
utile je sais pas si vous y avez
réfléchi c'est que dans le cadre du
Sommet du futur qui aura lieu en
septembre 2024 qui est une initiative du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU
il a proposé que nous signons
un pacte numérique mondial et
aujourd'hui il y a une grande
concertation qui a lieu à la fois des
gouvernements de la société civile les
entreprises l'OIF je crois doit faire
une intervention en tout cas la PF a été
interrogée par l'OIF pour voir comment
on pourrait promouvoir la francophonie
et apporter aussi dans ce cadre du
numérique de francophonie numérique à
certains nombre d'idées je trouve que
c'est un sujet qu'on trouverait tous
collectivement s'emparer que cette
perspective du pacte numérique mondial
pour faire vivre ses valeurs de la
diversité linguistique merci Laurence
Garnier
oui merci monsieur le Président merci à
Monsieur Toubon et à Monsieur de
cinétique de nous avoir partagé ce matin
cette passion de la langue française je
voulais revenir monsieur de cinétie sur
ce que vous avez évoqué concernant le
français dans l'entreprise qui me paraît
être un enjeu absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui moi je suis issue de
l'industrie automobile française qui
comme toutes les entreprises et touchées
par les nombreux anglicismes qui l'ont
envahi au cours de ces dernières
décennies et je crois que l'enjeu est en
réalité très fort parce que derrière les
changements de mots ça a été rappelé
aussi par mon collègue Pierre ouzouillas
il y a des changements de pratique des
changements de méthode des changements
de management je ne sais pas quel est le
terme académique qu'il faudrait utiliser
et des changements de culture
d'entreprise donc
je voulais revenir sur ce point vous
avez sans doute lu l'excellent livre de
Michel Vinaver qui nous a quitté l'année
dernière par dessus bord qui décrits
magnifiquement comment une entreprise
qui veut vendre du papier toilette bleu
blanc rouge cède en réalité à cette
anglicisation des méthodes des pratiques
avec voilà je vais pas spoiler le livre
de Michel vinavert qui est un livre
remarquable mais je crois vraiment qu'on
touche là à la façon dont l'entreprise
française et ça marque de fabrique peut
perdurer aujourd'hui dans le monde que
l'on connaît donc ma question c'était de
savoir quels outils
concrets vous pouvez mettre à
disposition des entreprises françaises
qui voudraient s'emparer de cet enjeu on
a parlé des collectivités on a parlé
bien sûr de l'État français mais pour
les entreprises pour les entreprises
industrielles françaises qui voudraient
se saisir de cette question comment
elles peuvent faire concrètement et
quels outils vous mettez à leur
disposition pour qu'elles puissent
déployer cet amour de la langue
française et de la culture d'entreprise
à la française
Olivier Pacaud
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs tout bon et de cinétique pour
vos propos passionnants alors
pour faire plaisir à Catherine Morin dci
je dirais que la start-up nation chère à
un éminent personnage français elle peut
être très fière de sa langue évidemment
parce que c'est pas seulement un trésor
patrimonial c'est aussi
un vecteur d'influence et de rayonnement
international c'est une véritable arme
en matière de soft power mais il faut
utiliser d'autres termes bien sûr
moi j'aurais une question très
anecdotique en fait mais j'ai beaucoup
apprécié votre
petite dissertation sur
Villers-Cotterêts il s'avère que je suis
élu de l'Oise non pas de laine mais
Villers-Cotterêts touchent l'Oise alors
vous avez commencé par dire que c'était
une zone un petit peu arriérée entre
guillemets mais vous avez un peu corrigé
après bon il y a Château-Thierry la
fontaine il y a Pierrefonds il y a
compiè et alors vous avez insisté sur le
rôle que les collectivités locales
désormais ont et peuvent avoir en
matière effectivement de soutien à la
langue il y a un très beau festival qui
a été créé très récemment qui s'appelle
paroles par les trois collectivités
concernés l'agglomération de la région
de Compiègne le pays de Valois le Pays
de Retz et alors c'est vrai que
Villers-Cotterêts c'était battant moi je
j'étais bluffé et je pense que ça va
être un outil formidable pour
développer la francophonie et avoir un
lieu un site incarné dans la pierre
c'est très important alors une petite
chose avant ma question anecdotique j'ai
regardé avec un peu de malice votre
petit livret et j'ai appris alors qu'on
dit pause au lieu de freeze mais en
français on dit break au lieu de
breakdance je sais pas si je prononce
bien break mais bon alors ma question
anecdotique on est aujourd'hui dans une
langue qui multiplie les acronymes
les acronymes ne sont pas nés avec le
21e siècle mon ami Pierre ouzouglas
pourra vous parler du Sénat tous
popularous mais aujourd'hui on en a
partout
de plus en plus pas seulement
dans notre langue française il y en a
partout alors est-ce que pour vous
l'acronyme qui nous submerge c'est un
enrichissement c'est un appauvrissement
comment vous considérez ça la chronique
elles achètent
merci monsieur le président
pour vos propos et pour votre engagement
engagement monsieur le ministre bien
connu pour la promotion et pour la
défense de notre belle langue française
alors nous le savons notre langue est
partie intégrante de notre identité vous
l'avez dit de notre patrimoine de notre
culture elle constitue également un
facteur de cohésion au sein de notre
société elle permet de créer des liens
et facilitent la compréhension
et les échanges et on voit bien à quel
point la langue française est un bien
précieux alors je reviendrai pas sur
tout ce qui a été dit sur la
Francophonie est très bien dit par notre
président du groupe et je salue ici
l'existence de ce groupe de travail sur
la francophonie puisqu'on voit bien à
quel point la langue française qui est
parlée par 320 millions de locuteurs
principaux et la cinquième et vous
l'avez répété la cinquième langue la
plus parlée du monde un certain nombre
de d'organisations notamment l'Assemblée
parlementaire de la Francophonie oeuvres
justement pour que perdure ce patrimoine
commun et permettre également de
sensibiliser les jeunes générations à
l'apprentissage de la langue française
et je pense que c'est indispensable de
pouvoir avoir aussi un engagement
vis-à-vis des jeunes générations et sur
le plan national et nous nous voyons la
loi que vous avez initié relative à
l'emploi de la langue française a permis
justement de garantir fortement à nos
citoyens un droit aux Français dans la
vie au quotidien dans le travail mais
également de pouvoir comprendre échanger
et rendre finalement la loi française
accessible et je crois que c'est un
enjeu et un souci qui doit être aussi le
nôtre constant avec des évolutions que
nous voyons vous avez évoqué
l'intelligence artificielle l'enjeu du
numérique mais nous voyons aussi en
parallèle qu'il y a un certain nombre
malheureusement d'atteintes à la langue
française nous l'avons évoqué sur la
question notamment de l'anglicisme je
voulais également vous sonder peut-être
sur une autre atteinte enfin que je
considère comme étant une atteinte qui
est finalement
une évolution un développement
grandissant de l'écriture qu'on dit
inclusive dans notre société alors je
considère à titre personnel que
l'écriture inclusive exclut davantage
que qu'elle inclut et pourtant nous la
voyons fleurir de plus en plus et
d'ailleurs l'actualité récente nous
livre encore une une parfaite
illustration dans le cadre d'un d'un
devoir enfin en tout cas d'un examen au
niveau universitaire avec des mots
finalement qui n'existent pas
l'utilisation de pronom qui qui
n'existent pas on voit bien à quel point
l'utilisation de l'écriture inclusive et
nous le voyons dans des documents
officiels de plus en plus dans des
municipalités je le vois même au sein de
la ville de Strasbourg fleurir dans des
règlement intérieur de nos collectivités
territoriales et je trouve
particulièrement avec notamment
l'utilisation du point du point médian à
quel point l'utilisation de l'écriture
inclusive complexifie justement cette
écriture à quel point également
elle rend finalement notre notre langue
peut accessible et je vraiment je
m'inquiète de cette évolution
avec
effectivement un accroissement de de
cette écriture et donc je voulais tout
simplement vous sonder puisque vous
parliez Monsieur le Délégué Général de
l'érosion de notre langue française et
qu'il fallait pouvoir en fait lutter
contre ce phénomène mais également
contre le taux d'illettrisme qui est de
plus en plus important comme vous l'avez
soulevé je vous remercie vous êtes
encore nombreux à vouloir intervenir
donc si vous pouviez
être synthétique d'avance merci Max
Brisson
je ne sais pas je suis pour tout à fait
répondre à votre injonction mais je
pense que mon intervention décalée peut
trouver un tout à fait sa place
monsieur d'abord je voudrais entrer en
bulle dire mon respect mon anniversaire
pour ce ministre et ma reconnaissance
pour le travail de Monsieur ledégénéral
que je peux mesurer sur d'autres
territoires dans d'autres rayons
d'actions l'importance
moi je trouve mes collègues peut-être
avec l'exception des achats
relativement soft si j'ose dire dans
leurs artères version
moi je suis
stupéfait quand même du décalage entre
le discours qui est tenu ici et la
réalité
je doute
que renforcement du cadre légal monsieur
le ministre vous l'avez dit faudrait-il
encore qu'il soit appliqué
ou des outils
dont parler Laurence Garnier puis se
suffire
s'il n'y a pas de volonté politique moi
je suis choqué
de la bandeau de toute volonté de
défendre langue française d'une grande
partie de nos élites
vous avez parlé de l'angle de cohésion
je voudrais bien vous suivre
ma condition que ceux qui tiennent l'eau
du pavé médiatique qu'il soit politique
économique culturelles universitaire
médiatique
monte un petit peu l'exemple de le
rattachement à la langue française le
dernier snobisme est à main de parler
anglais
et je trouve aujourd'hui que nos élites
sont largement responsables et que le
discours sur la cohésion je le dis avec
respect pour vous
avez porté
est quand même très très loin des
réalités de ceux qui devraient montrer
l'exemple
et qui finalement nous rappelle une
chose que moi je vécu comme un élu du
Pays Basque dans le monde des rapports
linguistique est dominant et dominé
c'est pas pierre
et qui a des rapports de force
et que ces rapports de force
ils ne sont pas aujourd'hui notre
avantage s'il n'y a pas une forte
mobilisation politique s'il y a pas une
forte de mobilisation de nos élites s'il
y a pas une réelle prise de conscience
et je doute que les moyens qui sont les
votes ou se déguise générale soit la
hauteur du défi
qui est le nôtre qui est celui comme
l'avait dit Jacques Chirac en son temps
de la diversité
linguistique de notre monde et donc sa
richesse
ce ministre
vous avez vous êtes l'auteur d'une loi
qui fête ses 30 ans
permettez-moi de vous dire avec respect
vous connaissez bien les antiques pour y
avoir servi
permettez-moi de dire que la loi tout
bon m'a laissé parfois un goût amer
parce que je l'ai vu servi par des hauts
fonctionnaires parfois avec zèle quand
il s'agissait déposer la langue
française face aux langues régionales
celle que je ne voyais rarement
lorsqu'il s'agissait de combattre la
domination anglaise sur la signalétique
dans les rues de peau de Bayonne
arrose le basque
ou le Gasco
et là je facilité donner à l'invasion de
la langue anglaise partout ailleurs
pourvu que le business puisse
fonctionner
c'est cela
le ressenti que je peux avoir et je suis
persuadé pour que largement la loi de
tout bon la Massour
a été largement détournée de sa fidélité
par des fonctionnaires zélés au nom de
jacody jacobinisme dépassé
alors qu'on aurait pu s'attendre au
contraire qu'il se retrouve dans un
combat pour la diversité qui fait que le
combat pour nous langue de France pour
la langue française et le même combat
celui de combat pour le pluralisme pour
une pour un monde de diversité qui ne
reçoit pas une langue un mode dominée
par le Glory s'entend bien de Paris je
te remercie
Bernard fiest
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Délégué monsieur le ministre
moi je donc dans peu dans le
prolongement des deux dernières
interventions moi je voudrais reprendre
un peu le document votre rapport sur la
langue française vous dites en page 32
que la loi tout bon est riche donc là en
français comme la langue de
l'enseignement des examens et concours
ainsi que des thèses et mémoires moi
j'aimerais avoir un petit
éclaircissement il me semble que
l'article 11 a été abrogé et je voudrais
savoir pourquoi l'article 11 qui
reprenait justement surnom et qu'est-ce
qui est quel est l'usage qui est fait
maintenant un peu de de ces obligations
quand même d'utiliser la langue
française même si je l'ai entendu on
respecte la liberté académique comme on
respecte la liberté des juges comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur l'ex ministre
des sceaux
Jacques opéra
merci président merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci Monsieur le Secrétaire
général le délégué général moi je
voudrais aller dans le sens de Max
prison plusieurs choses quatre points le
premier point cette création de citer de
la langue française c'était sur 85
millions d'euros c'est de 909 on ne sait
plus l'ouverture était prévue
normalement le 25 juin elle est décalée
moi je m'interroge vous parlais Monsieur
le Délégué général d'un choix symbolique
avec un territoire qui a des difficultés
socioculturelles qui a un maire aussi
rassemblement national il faut pas
l'oublier aussi moi je m'interroge sur
cette symbolique culturelle ce qu'il
doit avoir un coup aussi élevé ou si
élevé le deuxième point vous parlez
également de formidable opportunité le
directeur de la cité donc de la langue
française lui dit que c'est la
possibilité d'avoir une excuse pour
parler français est-ce qu'il faut voir
véritablement s'excuser pour parler
français et avoir un lieu pour pouvoir
le faire et j'irai plutôt dans de
Monsieur le Ministre tout bon je crois
que les Jeux olympiques sont un moment
qui sera dédié par les Français en tout
cas lorsque vous avez fait appel et
cette résolution pour que le Parlement
s'en sont en part de pouvoir faire en
sorte que le français soit la langue
officielle même si tous les sports ne
sont pas français la pelote basque bien
sûr et françaises mais je crois qu'il y
a d'autres d'autres choses est-ce qu'il
faut
accélérer ou augmenter les sanctions
pour qu'en France on puisse abandonner
partager cette langue je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit fonctionne par contre j'ai
super persuadé vous avez raison ce soit
le moment de réunion ou les moments où
chacun où les peuples se rencontrent qui
peuvent être des instants à mon avis
formidable et vis-à-vis de cela la
question c'est pas simplement la
francophonie c'est par les Français en
France et ça sera mon troisième point en
prolongement de des achats Schalke moi
je m'interroge vous parlais
d'intelligence bien sûr artificielle on
peut parler d'intelligence non
artificielle c'est en tout cas c'est le
de l'homme
lorsque dans l'écriture inclusive et
sous le prétexte de la liberté
pédagogique on laisse à des chefs
d'établissement ou à des professeurs de
faire des exercices ou des devoirs ou
dans tout cas des examens en écriture
inclusive ça pose question alors comment
le le créateur en tout cas l'auteur de
cette loi peut-il réagir vis-à-vis de
cela mais sa pose aussi problème pour
tous nos élèves étrangers qui vont
apprendre le français avec une écriture
inclusive alors que le français est déjà
quelque chose de compliqué donc une
écriture qui est quasiment illisible et
enfin la dernière question la dernière
intervention sur le 4e point c'est le
ministre que reste-t-il pas de nos
amours mais qui reste-t-il 30 ans après
de de votre loi du 4 août 94 je me
rappelle je me souviens que c'est
l'emploi de la langue française mais pas
simplement c'est sur la désignation
l'offre ensuite mon point de suspension
facture etc et quittance moi je vous ai
parlé du regret de communication privée
vis-à-vis du Conseil constitutionnel
dernier point est-ce que vous avez
d'autres regrets ou peut-être est-ce que
vous avez d'autres espoirs pour que ça
puisse évoluer merci
Sylvie Robert
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre et Monsieur le
Délégué Général pour vos propos alors
mon cher max je ne sais pas si je vais
être soft mais tu quand même employer
éviter d'employer cet anglicisme pardon
alors je sais pas après comment tu le
traduis mais faisons attention mais je
partage en tout cas tes propos non moi
j'irai sur un autre
une autre dimension qui en fait
finalement nous réunit tous ce matin
c'est de considérer que peu que ce soit
au Parlement sur le gouvernement
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous demander si
vous connaissez le nom de la secrétaire
d'État la francophonie aujourd'hui dans
le gouvernement dites moi dites-moi
donc voilà je je
vais non mais voyez je pense que essaie
de notre responsabilité et je voudrais
remercier Laurent Lafond d'avoir non
mais sérieusement je suis très très
sérieux sur ce point-là d'avoir organisé
cette audition parce que je peux que je
trouve que aujourd'hui
personne ou peu demande considère que la
question de la langue est un enjeu
politique majeur
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes au temps
dans ces complexités dans ces
questionnements-là sur la question de la
diversité des langues régionales sur la
question de l'enseignement sur la
question de l'éducation parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous perdons en influence
alors que c'est un élément de diplomatie
culturelle extrêmement important et que
finalement personne ne s'y intéresse
véritablement et je voudrais commencer
par là parce que il y a plein d'éléments
qui me font dire qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement dans notre pays mais pas
seulement au niveau européen au niveau
cette question là n'est pas considérée
comme un enjeu politique ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point je
voudrais être brève Villers-Cotterêts
moi d'ailleurs j'invite tous mes
collègues à visiter ce magnifique
château de François 1er magnifiquement
restauré j'y ai passé deux jours je
trouve que c'est une réalisation
absolument remarquable pour autant le
chef de l'État a voulu et j'espère que
ce pari sera réussi que ce soit en
quelque sorte
de quintessence ou de révélations de cet
enjeu là politique que finalement la
place de nos langues dans la société
française et dans le monde de façon
générale parce que c'est c'est aussi
vraiment la question en tout cas
mondiale qui se pose alors
vous avez monsieur le dégagé général
très justement rappelé des enjeux ils
sont
cruciaux la question de l'encrage
territorial la question de la création
et la question de l'innovation
aujourd'hui pour que ce lieu soit
véritablement rendre visible et
permettent finalement à chacune et à
chacun d'entre nous de prendre
conscience de l'enjeu que représente là
et les langues de France quel est pour
vous l'élément déterminant dans le
projet de Villers-Cotterêts qui fera que
le pari sera réussi
je le dis d'autant plus que vous avez
parlé de résidence aujourd'hui si nous
et vous le savez on en a parlé il y a
hier quand nous sommes rencontrés ils
devaient y avoir un hôtel il n'y a plus
d'hôtel il n'y a pas de résident pour
les artistes ou les chercheurs alors
même qu'on pourrait imaginer dans
l'évolution de ce projet la possibilité
de le faire justement évoluer au regard
du contexte qui quand même extrêmement
préoccupant de la présence aujourd'hui
et de on va dire de la défense de nos
langues est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pensez que ce projet peut évoluer et
quel sera les éléments déterminant qui
permettra finalement que le pari sera
réussi je vous remercie Pierre Antoine
Lévy
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre Monsieur le Délégué
Général bon pas mal de questions ont été
posées monsieur le ministre la loi que
vous avez mis en place il y a quasiment
30 ans interdit l'usage de tout
anglicisme par toute personne morale de
droit public et toute personne privée
chargée d'une mission de droit public
cependant l'éclairs numériques et la
prévalence du languedit sur Internet
comme on me le voit assez régulièrement
cette loi semble rencontrer de nombreux
défis comment envisagez-vous
l'application de cette loi a l'air du
numérique ou l'anglais est largement
utilisé pensez-vous que la loi tout bon
nécessite des modifications ou des
adaptations pour répondre aux défis
actuels et ensuite une question qui
concerne plutôt la publicité puisque la
loi tout bon cible toutes les formes de
publicité l'exception des communications
par voie électroniques cette exception
semble de plus en plus problématique à
mesure que les communications numériques
deviennent des vecteurs de plus en plus
important pour la publicité
l'information
alors Monsieur quel est votre opinion
sur cette exception pensez-vous qu'elle
devrait être abordée dans une future
révision de la tout bon et si oui
comment imaginez-vous que cela pourrait
être d'une le fait d'une manière qui
respecte à la fois la liberté
d'expression et l'intégrité de la langue
française
et enfin Cédric VIAL
merci président très rapidement
effectivement ce que un certain nombre
de choses ont déjà été dites
j'ai trois questions finalement vous
avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre Monsieur le Délégué que que la
politique de la Francophonie était
rattaché à la politique des Affaires
extérieures de la France des Affaires
étrangères des affaires étrangères de la
France ma question est assez simple la
réponse peut être un peu moins comment
voyez-vous l'avenir je demande la
Francophonie avec l'extinction
progressive de l'influence française en
Afrique notamment et comment comment
concilier une politique francophone et
efficace avec une perte d'influence
importante dans dans un certain nombre
de pays notamment sur le continent
africain mais on pourrait citer aussi
l'Indo Pacifique deuxième question on
remarque ça a été dit sur finalement on
parle quasiment j'ai entendu parler on
va pas prendre c'est le terme mais de
grands remplacement du français par
l'anglais dans un certain nombre de de
pratiques est-ce que finalement
l'ennemi entre entre guillemets de la
langue française c'est vraiment
l'anglais comme ça pouvait peut-être
être le cas au moment où vous avez édité
votre loi monsieur le ministre ou est-ce
que l'ennemi ce n'est pas finalement le
français lui-même avec des dérives dont
on a parlé l'écriture inclusive ou de
l'orthographe
la pratique du français en France ne
possède pas un problème majeur à la
défense à la promotion du français à
l'extérieur de la France et Jean Jean ma
troisième question est Elias celle-ci
sur un air un peu sarcastique mais
finalement est-ce que la première cible
de la politique de la Francophonie
française devrait plutôt que la
politique étrangère devrait pas être la
politique intérieure et faut-il
rattacher ce ministère non plus
peut-être aux Affaires étrangères mais
au ministère de l'Intérieur peut-être
voilà comme quoi la francophonie peut
nous mener de loin dans la réflexion
politique et sociétale de nombreuses
questions des sujets assez divers mais
qui montrent vous le saviez
l'attachement de notre commission à ce
sujet et je me réjouis d'ailleurs que
nous puissions l'aborder ce matin à
votre présence je vais je m'excuse juste
par avance je vais devoir vous quitter
j'en suis désolé mais Max Brisson va
prendre le relais je me lance oui
évidemment vous avez évoqué tellement de
sujets donc je vais prendre un certain
nombre de points sur lesquels je vais
donner mon mon bras des réponses c'est
pas vrai des je vais donner mon opinion
et puis
d'autres c'est Paul qui
prend dans le relais et qui répondra je
le prends dans l'ordre d'hiver je
commence simplement par
un point qui est incontestable nous
devons absolument appliquer notre
politique de la langue avoir une
politique de la langue dans le monde
numérique voilà bon je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails mais il est clair que
vous êtes là-dessus
je crois placer pour
réfléchir à une extension de la loi tout
bon de nouvelles dispositions qui
relèveraient de tout ce que vous faites
ici au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée sur le le
numérique mais voyez
l'intelligence artificielle comme chacun
sait
c'est justement comme la langue des
autres ce sera très bien
moins mais je lisais dans un magazine
récemment quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé c'est le travail qui est fait
sur les langues africaines avec l'usage
de l'intelligence artificielle il y a
avec chat tchipi on envisage de lancer
une entreprise de traduction automatique
des 2000 langues africaines
2000 et on va se retrouver en quelque
sorte avec
si c'est bien fait un outil qui
permettra de jouer non pas ce qui s'est
produit avec l'anglais depuis des
siècles l'uniformisation mais au
contraire la
diversité et je pense que
nous avons
de ce point de vue sur la francophonie à
faire un grand effort c'est la
francophonie
dépasse je l'ai dit la diplomatie et que
nous entrions aujourd'hui dans la
technologie et c'est de ce point de vue
un des intérêts de Villers parce que à
Villers-Cotterêts il y aura
justement dans ce centre lingua etc ce
qui me paraît relever de cette politique
d'innovation au service de notre de
notre langue je fais de deux petites
deux petites parenthèses
je sais plus qui au tout début m'a
interrogé c'est vous rapporter je crois
sur le monsieur le Président sur les
visas
c'est
notamment pour l'Afrique ça me remet en
mémoire
une conversation avec le président
Chirac en 95 je me souviens qu'on était
dans une réunion
il faisait
un discours je sais plus exactement et
et il y avait 4 ou 5 personnes qui
l'aidait à relire ce discours enfin ce
discours je suis et à un moment à un
moment la question c'est posé de
la circulation les droits des étrangers
les titres de séjour etc s'est tourné
vers moi et il m'a dit mais
pourquoi il faut des papiers pourquoi
faire des papiers pourquoi est-ce que
les africains viennent pas en France
comme ils veulent bon voilà et alors je
lui dis
elle était déjà qui a des règles genre
des étrangers et bien je commençais à
dire deux ou trois choses comme ça et il
dit mais arrêtez Jacques avec vos
arguties juridiques voilà c'était une
mot qui l'emploi et il avait de vision
quelque sorte très
universaliste comme ça et je crois que
c'est une vraie question qui se pose
aujourd'hui on est parti exactement
inverse c'est-à-dire l'identitarisme les
frontières tac tac tac tac plus je fais
de petites boîtes et plus les petites
boîtes sont étanches mieux je me trouve
et bien je pense qu'il faut revenir en
arrière à une certaine vision et et
voilà je dis ça parce que c'est je
voudrais juste de ce point de ajouter
une autre chose sur Villers-Cotterêts je
dis tout de suite que moi dès la rentrée
je suis pour et je pense contrairement à
ce que beaucoup craignent que ça va
réussir bon c'est à dire que ça sera pas
un château vide bon
au château
je dis deux choses l'une personne de l'a
dit Villers-Cotterêts c'est Alexandre
Dumas c'est le général Dumas un métis
général etc et c'est Alexandre Dumas
c'est-à-dire l'auteur de très loin le
plus lu après la Bible dans le monde en
tout cas en français bon et donc et donc
je pense qu'il faut exploiter ça et
c'est c'est parce que c'est extrêmement
porteur et pas seulement auprès de ceux
qui
a Dakar ou Abidjan ont de fait leur
humanité
à partir de ça il y a une autre
considération l'autre est pratique il y
a une institution qui a récemment pris
un très bon développement et a fait une
très bonne réussite
et qui au départ
avaient les mêmes interrogations c'est
le château de Chaumont qui est devenu
aujourd'hui vous le savez le Centre
national du paysage le le c'est à la
fois de l'art contemporain la nature etc
et ça a très bien alors il y a une
grande différence avec bière Cotterêts
c'est que
bière que très CNM etc et nationale et
Chaumont ça a été il y a quelques années
régionalisées et je pense que c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles ça marche
très bien c'est parce que c'est
l'établissement public régional non mais
je me permets de le dire mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on peut s'inspirer
de ce qui a été fait à Chaumont et par
Chantal Colle Dumont ça directrice pour
la réussite de de
Villers-Cotterêts mais en tout cas mais
en tout cas je dis il faut absolument
faire un investissement et ici je pense
que
avec la les commissions qui s'occupent
de technologie qui sont euconomie il
faut probablement que vous travailliez
là-dessus pour soit eu dans le une loi
numérique introduire la langue française
soit maître du numérique dans la loi de
80 14
je une question a été posée qui est une
question récurrente extrêmement
importante
sur les revues scientifiques de manière
générale le langage dans la science
c'est vrai que la loi fioration qui a
été votée il y a quelques années à Miyan
cause l'article 11
il y a un travail à faire ce travail il
passe notamment par le fait de financer
davantage
la possibilité de faire de la traduction
et il faut donc y consacrer des des
moyens mais
je ne suis pas
totalement pessimiste là-dessus et je
pense que beaucoup de nos scientifiques
nos chercheurs tiennent encore la rampe
de ce point de de ce point de de vue
là communication institutionnelle
là-dessus je vous renvoie à un travail
qui a été fait par la l'Académie
française
au début de
au début de 2022 mais qui pour diverses
raisons
querelle interne dans cette grande
maison d'immortel
n'est sorti que vers la fin de l'année
et là dedans il y a des choses d'abord
il y a des constatations naturellement
qui vont vous faire vous le savez tous
dressés les cheveux sur la tête enfin
ceux qui ne sont pas comme moi
c'est-à-dire ceux qui en ont et
que vous
mais en même temps mais en même temps
on voit bien que
la
l'Académie française a bien vu le sujet
je me permets de lire ainsi la
propagation massive et continue d'un
vocabulaire anglo américain souvent
dénaturé
considéré à tort comme bien connu du
public général et d'emploi quasi
universel a pour conséquence
contradictoire le risque d'en
approvision en proportion du lexique
français et d'une discrimination
croissante entre les publics en effet la
volonté d'atteindre une cible
paradoxalement aussi étendue
qu'inférencier
pour ceux qui utilisent le langage
anglais plus universel procède une
illusion
l'Académie française dit quelque chose
que je trouve exactement et qui
contredit quelque chose que quelqu'un
d'entre vous a dit tout à l'heure on ne
touche en fait qu'une frange réduite
privilégiée éduquer de la population
maîtrisant les langues étrangères et
notamment l'anglais seul une proportion
restreinte des usagers et consommateurs
est en mesure d'appréhender pleinement
le discours en vogue sans pour autant
l'unanimant l'apprécier c'est justement
dans l'insuffisance prise en compte des
attentes et des possibilités du public
le plus large que réside les difficultés
constatées par la commission la
commission de l'Académie française je me
permets de le dire parce que c'est
complètement en phase avec ce que je dis
depuis le début est-ce que on a dit ce
matin la loi sur la langue loi non pas
élitiste les gens qui parlent anglais
seraient les gens qui qui travaillent
etc et puis ceux qui parlent le français
ceux qui auraient le temps de livre de
lire le dernier prix Goncourt non c'est
pas vrai c'est au contraire un
instrument
[Musique]
Laurence Garnier a posé une question
mais je pense que Paul pourra y répondre
je voudrais juste indiquer que spoiler
est un mot français
c'est alors si l'heure on peut dire
spoiler d'ailleurs bon mais à l'origine
français non mais tout ça non mais je
dis ça parce que je dis ça parce que
on voit bien que il y a une grande
complexité dans cette dans cette affaire
et que à partir de moment où plus de 60%
de la langue anglaise vient de l'autre
côté de la Manche aujourd'hui je vais
voir
ça s'est passé en l'an 1000 c'était pas
passé mais ça c'est continué au 18e
siècle au 19e etc donc il y a des une
relativité à trouver dans la durée dans
la guerre des des des langues
je laisserai à Paul le soin de parler
de l'écriture inclusive tout simplement
parce que ma loi comme vous le savez et
j'y ai toujours insisté ne dis pas quel
français il faut parler elle dit il faut
parler français mais vous pouvez faire
le français
comme on dit de la banlieue vous pouvez
parler le français du Parlement il est
spécial moi j'ai souvent beaucoup
d'amusement à lire les comptes-rendus
parlementaires d'autant que j'ajoute je
le dis aux personnes du compte-rendu le
les fonctionnaires du compte-rendu ont
aussi des des tics de langage en quelque
sorte c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs
je me suis à une époque dans les dans
les années 80 je me suis intéressé à ça
dans les nuits profondes à l'époque on
faisait des débages qu'à 3h du matin et
quand je ressortais je parlais quand je
ressortais je parlais avec les derniers
qui étaient avec moi c'est-à-dire les
fonctionnaires du compte-rendu et je me
souviens très bien il y avait une
manière de je parle de compte-rendu
analytique celui qui consiste à en 10
lignes ce qui a pris une heure c'est
vraiment c'est un exercice
intellectuellement et linguistiquement
absolument fabuleux bon je rends hommage
à ceux qui le font mais je pense que
nous nous avons nous avons là
la limite de notre travail la langue et
je bats moi contre tout
en matière de langue je pense que le
fixisme c'est le déclin le mouvement
c'est l'avenir il faut absolument ça
veut pas dire encore une fois n'importe
quoi mais surtout les et et et il ne
faut pas que la promotion de la langue
française soit pour les conservateurs et
que les progressistes soient contre
parce que là on est et c'est là où
ce qui m'avait je dois le dire
aujourd'hui encore ici au collègues de
gauche ce qui m'avait tué moi c'est que
ce soit le bon socialiste qui envoie ma
loi au conseil de professionnel en
94 et qui fasse tomber l'article 2 voilà
bon franchement
ça m'a d'autant que d'autant que je le
rappelle cette loi elle était un avatar
de la loi préparée par Catherine taska
un an avant bon
là je me suis posé des questions je
continue d'ailleurs je continue à me les
appeler
je pense que je j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait faire attention et je le
dis notamment parce que Max pression a
bien souligné ça c'est que effectivement
l'anglais c'est un certain
snobisme et j'ai c'est pour ça que j'ai
lu ce passage de l'Académie française du
rapport de l'Académie française tout à
l'heure parce que et effectivement il y
a deux façons de d'utiliser l'anglais il
y a cette espèce d'avachissement
d'utilisation de ces mots passent
partout qu'on va voir tout donc c'est
plutôt le globish et puis il y a
parlé anglais c'est pour les gens les
dirigeants d'entreprises les personnes
qui voyagent et je crois que il faut que
nous fassions très attention et encore
une fois je reviens toujours au même
sujet le français est un instrument de
politique sociale si en tout cas
un instrument de cohésion
sociale
et
je terminerai simplement
ces remarques
en citant
un philosophe qu'on aime qu'on n'aime
pas mais Jacques derida il a fait il a
dit une phrase que j'aime beaucoup c'est
ma langue mais elle ne m'appartient pas
et bien si
vous voulez que le français soit ce
qu'on veut c'est à dire porteur de notre
nation de notre citoyenneté de notre
politique de notre économie etc
il faut qu'elle ne nous appartient pas
il faut que nous ayons la capacité et et
je dirais de croire qu'elle est capable
d'être utilisé par d'autres qu'elle peut
bouger etc et je trouve que cette
expression de de Derrida
particulièrement intéressante c'est la
mienne mais elle ne m'appartient pas et
je pense que c'est ça le nœud même du
travail sur la sur le le la langue je
peux aussi terminer c'est plus c'est
plus classique peut-être par une
académicienne que vous avez peut-être
reçu ici d'ailleurs par cette grande
spécialiste de ces questions Barbara
Cassin aujourd'hui
la loi tout bon
qui contraint à l'usage du français
favorise en même temps l'enrichissement
terminologique et la traduction
[Musique]
et la bague de fer
parce qu'elle parlait de du colonialisme
qui est le français colonial peut
devenir
butin de guerre et langue d'émancipation
et je termine par où j'ai commencé c'est
à dire en me tournant vers ces 500 600
700 millions de personnes pour
lesquelles la langue française ne nous
appartient pas mais dont ils vont être
les porteurs dans les décennies qui
viennent
merci Monsieur général vous reste-t-il
des réponses à apporter à nos collègues
assez rapidement en effet on pourrait
aussi rajouter une autre citation de
Barbara Cassin que je trouve
intéressantes
Barbara Cassin qui comme vous le savez
sans doute fait partie du commissariat
scientifique sous la direction de Xavier
north
du quel travail également
zefgravier et Hassan Kouyaté ce dernier
étant comme vous le savez aussi le
directeur du festival dédié à la
Francophonie à Limoges donc cette
citation de Barbara Cassin que j'ai
aussi en tête contre cette idée
probablement naïve et dangereuse d'un
fixisme de la langue une langue pure ça
pue évidemment c'est un peu plus trivial
vous m'en excuserez mais ça montre bien
que la langue est dans un mouvement
permanent et que sans le dialogue
qu'elle peut entretenir avec les autres
langues elle ne peut pas s'enrichir
alors sur les quelques points sur
lesquels je pourrais répondre
je ne suis pas tout à fait de votre avis
monsieur le sénateur lorsque vous parlez
d'une absence de vision globale
concernant la stratégie de la politique
de la langue et de la Francophonie je
l'avais rappelé dans mon intervention
luminaire il y a
cette ce plan ce plan très ambitieux
pour la langue française et le plus
runinguisme porté par le Président de la
République le Chef de l'État en mars
2018 et qui propose de façon extrêmement
concrète un certain nombre de mesures à
prendre pour faire vivre la langue dans
une perspective d'ouverture et dans une
dynamique en faveur du plurilinguisme
c'est probablement cela d'ailleurs la
nouveauté dans le dans le discours porté
par le au plus haut niveau de l'État
j'ajouterai aussi que c'est probablement
la première fois ça c'est il suffit de
constater à travers l'histoire que
depuis le général de Gaulle un chef de
l'État
prend le sujet de la langue abra le
corps et tâche d'y apporter des réponses
il faut le saluer
l'autre ça veut dire évidemment un
travail interministériel renforcé il y a
des réunions régulières qui se passent à
l'Élysée notamment en interministérielle
on travaille très étroitement avec avec
les services de la secrétaire d'État
d'accord au boulot qui fait un travail
remarquable au ministère étrangères
secrétaire d'État à la Francophonie on
travaille également très étroitement
avec le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et avec un certain nombre
d'opérateurs en charge de ces sujets moi
je je vous je vous engage je vous invite
à
solliciter une autre une autre une autre
audition concernant le bilan du plan
présidentiel allons-y et vous vous
pourrez constater que nous avons
beaucoup avancé sur sur un grand nombre
de sujets
la question de la science est de l'usage
du français alors moi je considère pas
du tout contrairement peut-être à
d'autres voix y compris
l'institutions très très reconnue et
respectable que la bataille du français
dans le domaine scientifique est perdu
d'abord il faut savoir de quoi l'on
parle lorsqu'on parle de science on
parle des sciences humaines et sociales
en l'occurrence
la langue française moi je suis
optimiste restera un outil fondamental
puisque elle constitue en tant que tel
un objet de recherche
dans le domaine de la philosophie des
sciences humaines et sociales dans les
sciences exactes en effet on peut
constater un recul très fort de la
pratique et de l'emploi du français en
vérité moi ce qui me préoccupe le plus
c'est pas tellement que ça se passe en
anglais que ça soit diffusé en anglais
ce qui me préoccupe c'est que on ne soit
plus en mesure de la part des auteurs
scientifiques
de créer en français
car c'est la langue qui porte une vision
du monde et à partir du moment où on a
pu la capacité d'exprimer en premier
dans sa langue ses réalités les plus
modernes
de travaux de recherche scientifiques et
bien la langue la langue s'étiole la
langue se folklorise
il y a quand même des signaux
intéressants il y a l'initiative del
sinki qui avait été prise en 2019 en
faveur de la science ouverte au nom
d'une démocratisation et d'un partage
des savoirs et du rôle du citoyen
au plan collaboratif
en Europe notamment
avec une demande forte d'un certain
nombre de pays pourtant de tradition
fortement anglo-saxonnes à ce que enfin
on puisse
diffuser et traduire dans la langue
de la personne à qui l'on s'adresse
et donc ça je trouve que c'est très
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
cette prise de conscience avec à travers
le programme des sciences ouvertes
se fait des pays improbables de ce point
de vue là comme la Norvège les Pays-Bas
les pays baltes
revendiquent de nouveau dans cette
perspective une réutilisation de leur de
leur langue
et puis il y a travers la mission de sur
la découvrabilité des conditions
scientifiques que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre qui s'inscrit dans dans le cadre
d'un dialogue franco-québecois
car le Québec comme toujours et je le
retire mon chapeau et en avance sur ces
sujets
qui s'inscrit dans la continuité de ceux
qui a été fait dans le domaine des
industries culturelles et créatives nous
allons
imaginer avec des laboratoires des
laboratoires pardon de recherche
d'université française et québécoise en
partenariat avec le ministère de la
langue française tiens n'oublions pas
ministère de la langue française créé il
y a un an au Québec
non plus ne l'oublions pas réforme du
cadre légal québécois la loi 101
maintenant a été brogée au profit d'une
loi 96 beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
dynamique et d'une certaine façon
également contraignante quant à l'emploi
du français
soyons attentifs à ces signaux que nous
que nous donne nos amis et nos
partenaires privilégiés que peuvent être
les Québécois
donc inscrire cette cette démarche de
mission
conjointe également en lien avec le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche en France
le scientifique en chef québécois pour
imaginer les conditions d'une d'un
espace collaboratif en langue française
dans le domaine scientifique en mettant
à disposition des outils traduction
automatique en mettant à disposition des
outils rédactionnels
parce que l'avenir je pense de la
recherche des sciences expérimentales
exactes et bien il se joue là dans la
capacité que nous avons à favoriser la
traduction en anglais
en permettant aux chercheurs de
continuer ou de reprendre la langue
française comme langue de travail c'est
fondamental
troisième sujet
enfin on est quand même tous très
engagés et
dans le cadre de l'Organisation
internationale de la Francophonie pour
une stratégie justement numérique et
ambitieuse on a parlé de la
découvrabilité on a parlé monsieur le
ministre l'a évoqué des sujets liés à
l'IA au tal au traitement automatique
des langues
on ne peut pas y arriver ensemble
j'avais évoqué la démarche absolument
indispensable à prendre au plan européen
mais nous allons également adopter une
démarche similaire au plan francophone
et donc le sommet de Djerba qui s'est
déroulé à l'automne dernier comme vous
le savez le Sommet de la Francophonie a
donné en perspective des objectifs très
précis concernant la francophonie
numérique et scientifique et
ces objectifs et bien nous allons les
tenir on pourra revenir en détail sur un
certain nombre d'entre eux si vous le
souhaitez changer notamment je l'ai déjà
évoqué sur la question de la
découvrabilité des contenus
scientifiques
ils vont être réalisés ils vont être
valorisés lors du prochain Sommet de la
Francophonie qui se tiendra en France et
notamment à Villers à Villers-Cotterêts
vous évoquiez le sujet dans le fond
madame la sénatrice du
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire que
Villers-Cotterêts marche ou pas vous
avez déjà un premier témoignage d'un
visiteur de de du chantier qui
qui dont on ne peut pas douter la
persualité et qui est enthousiaste moi
je vais vous dire il y a il y a un sujet
qui est majeur et qui va être un lieu
principal d'attractif pour les
prochaines années bien sûr il y a encore
des questions d'investissement
pour créer des centres hôteliers des
infrastructures de services
supplémentaires mais il y a déjà une
réalisation qui va être proposée à son
inauguration
en
à la fin de l'été de cette année
de la cité
c'est le parcours permanent on va
proposer sur 1300 mètres carrés un
parcours permanent dédié à la langue
française
interactif dédié à la langue française
dans son histoire dans son lien
constitutif qui qui avec la nation dans
son dans son expansion dans sa diffusion
dans son dans son déploiement et dans
son enrichissement grâce aux espaces des
mondes francophones mais également
donner toute sa place au plurilinguisme
à la place des langues régionales
monsieur le sénateur j'espère que vous
en serez heureux et on pourra vous
accueillir à Villers-Cotterêts pour que
vous puissiez découvrir ces dispositifs
car je suis de votre avis
on a été beaucoup trop Jacobins par le
passé on a eu une tendance à considérer
que les langues régionales étaient des
patois
ça il suffit de il y a quelques quelques
années en 1794 de son référé à l'ouvrage
tristement célèbre de l'abbé Grégoire de
l'universalité de la langue française et
de l'anéantissement des patois je crois
que c'était à peu près cela donc on voit
que la machine jacobine a été
extrêmement lourde et redoutable pour
les pour les langues régionales mais le
projet de Villers-Cotterêts c'est de
donner une place à la langue française à
son histoire à la langue française dans
l'expression de toute sa diversité la
francophonie mais également dans son
dialogue avec les autres langues y
compris et d'abord avec celle qui sont
employés sur le territoire de la
République
je crois qu'il convient de rappeler de
rappeler cela aussi
sur toujours pour terminer sur la
question des langues régionales qui est
une question très importante
ça ne vous aura pas non plus échappé
avec la création d'une instance Conseil
national des langues et culture
régionales voulues par le Premier
ministre en mars
2022 Jean Castex
c'est une nouvelle instance de dialogue
entre les acteurs des langues régionales
et l'État qui a été mise en place
le secrétariat général on a été confié à
la Délégation générale à la langue
française de langue de France et nous
devons avant la fin du mois de juillet
soutenir une prochaine session qui sera
présidée par la ministre de la Culture
aimable
cet instant sera un lieu de dialogue qui
permettra justement de d'accompagner des
projets tangibles concrets qu'on soit
pas uniquement dans la posture mais
qu'on soit aussi dans dans l'action
l'écriture inclusive l'écriture
inclusive alors moi je vais
si vous le autorisez
me cantonner au texte réglementaire
celui du 21 novembre 2017 circulaire PM
qui a été
signé par Edouard Philippe et qui promet
la féminisation des noms de métiers sont
des d'accord qui promet
la le recours systématique je cite de la
double flexion dans les actes de
recrutement et les avis de vacances
publiés au Journal officiel et qui
exclut le point médian car
on peut dire beaucoup de choses sur
l'écriture inclusive
le sujet
l'irritant c'est bien le point médian et
là les textes réglementaires sont très
claires textes réglementaire qui a été
d'ailleurs renforcée par une autre
circulaire un autre niveau de du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Jean-Marc Jean-Marie Jean-Michel pardon
Blanquer daté du 6 mai 2021 et qui
énonce le même principe pour les actes
administratives et les pratiques
d'enseignement et qui prohibent
absolument en tous les cas le point
médian et là on en revient à ce que
disait Jacques Toubon notre rôle n'est
pas de prononcer sur le corpus d'une
langue ni sur son
illusoire pureté notre objet c'est être
vigilant pour que ce bien commun que
notre langue soit accessible et
maîtrisable par tous et donc le point
médian constitue un obstacle indéniable
à la maîtrise et à l'accès de la langue
voilà est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
j'ai oublié d'autres d'autres sujets je
crois que je crois que non monsieur
dégageradan
il nous reste monsieur le ministre se
dégagera là à vous remercier pour je
crois ce moment de qualité
je le dis à certaines avec son parti qui
nous a changé un petit peu de tous les
toutes les discussions que vous avez
autour du sport depuis quelques quelques
semaines c'était un moment je crois très
agréable très important vous remercions
nouveau monsieur ministre se déguisé
général je crois d'abord deux trois
éléments
oui la française ne nous appartient pas
à partir de l'humanité mais nous avons
je crois des devoirs particuliers et
c'est ce que les sénatrices et sénateurs
ont voulu exprimer avec force oui nous
souhaitons la réussite de
Villers-Cotterêts que cela soit dit on a
pu ici ou là mettre des critiques sur
les origines mais nous souhaitons tous
que ce projet soit réussi pour la France
et pour la langue française
vous avez bien compris aussi Monsieur le
Ministre
commission de la culture du Sénat on est
capable de dépasser les oppositions
partisanes qui vous aurait été peut-être
bien utile par 1994 et que nous pouvons
avoir et vous l'avez senti ce matin des
combats communs pour une langue
française qui soit bien sûr en mouvement
comme vous l'avez dit mais qui sont
aussi une langue de cohésion je crois
que c'est le message ce matin qui a été
exprimé avec beaucoup de force pas
beaucoup d'entre nous nous souhaitons
pas que la langue française qui a été
une langue dans notre histoire de
cohésion et d'unités deviennent une
langue de fracture et de discrimination
et je crois que c'était le message que
vous voulez vous exprimer ce matin les
sénatrices et d'être et le dialogue que
nous avons eu avec vous merci Monsieur
ministre merci Monsieur Davy Gérard
merci